[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian's
chief political correspondent
jessica elgot and the political editor
of the sun harry cole with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
the front pages then let's start with
the metro time to end the online hate
the metro reports on a call for a
david's law to tackle internet trolls
the guardian leading with the same story
with an image of mps holding a minute
silence to pay tribute to their lost
colleague david amos
the eye leads on mps vowing to continue
to meet the public face to face in the
wake of sir david's murder while meeting
constituents
meanwhile david amos local paper the
echo leads with the news that south end
will become a city fulfilling one of the
late mp's wishes
the daily mail has a cctv image showing
a man understood to be ali habi ali the
suspect arrested on suspicion of killing
sir david walking along a north london
street just hours before the mp was
killed
the telegraph reports on warnings from
experts that the covid vaccine booster
program is moving too slowly leaving the
most vulnerable at risk over the winter
the financial times leads on the
possibility of an interest rate rise
soon as soon as next month in fact to
tackle inflation
and the stun the sun even has a story on
strictly dancer katya jones
so jessica and harry are here with us
and after a very difficult weekend harry
that was perhaps the best of uh of our
parliament today
yes um but with a sort of grim from the
familiarity about it all um it was felt
there's a sort of mood of uh of grim
awareness in westminster
thinking a lot about
memory of pc keith palmer who died in
the in the new palace yard um killed by
a radical terrorist and of course joe
cox who died in her constituency killed
by a radical terrorist and it's um
yeah it's it's it's it it is great it
was the best of uh the best of our
apartment but it's one side parliament
you never really want to see
um and you know the tributes were
flowing tonight the
church service i thought was
particularly moving uh and you know sort
of
a silver lining of joy in south end that
they've finally got their city status
that david amos has been banging on
about for the better part of 20 years um
but again in a scenario that you know no
one wants to see it's sort of good news
but you know in the circumstances that
you know everyone wishes would have not
happened yeah south end i mean such
poignancy
he he would have loved to see that
happen wouldn't he um you know i
couldn't imagine yeah absolutely
absolutely i mean a real fitting tribute
and actually quite emotional when that
announcement came for many in the house
no doubt uh many of whom you know
desperately struggled to hold on to
their emotions today as they paid
tribute and with with great humor which
reflected the man obviously but let's
move on to the policy that that might
evolve from this um the guardian your
paper in fact your article jessica uh
this idea to crack down on social media
abuse of public figures um most
specifically by ending online anonymity
so tell us more about about your article
yeah so this was a proposal by um mark
francois one of the a good friend of
david ames he called him his political
mentor um and he talked about how
um
rather than this being specifically
linked to
to david's killing it's more that he
said that this is something that david
himself had
been
concerned about in recent years he'd
written about in his book he talked
about how
um difficult he'd found it seeing
particularly female mps female
colleagues experiencing online abuse and
and you know mark francois said that he
was prepared to to drag the the the
twitter and facebook ceos to the house
of commons and and make them hear the
the the you know the tales that mps
could tell about how much abuse they'd
received and and you know he's mentioned
ending online anonymity that's not
something that's currently in the bill
but pretty patel said that she you know
she was she was interested in making the
build tougher
i think there were a lot of arguments
around this um
you know the debate today wasn't about
having those arguments really it was
about paying tribute remembering
um to david and and you know everything
that he brought to politics but um you
know i think in the coming days there
may well be a debate about you know how
much does this kind of move
really really change um the you know
what what happened to him and i mean
obviously we've still got something to
be charged but as as um
as harry said that you know the the
incident we've seen in incidents we've
seen in recent years in the killing of
joe cox appealing killing of pc um
palmer attacks on other mps including
stephen timms they would they were
mainly by lone wolf radical terrorists
where they might you know you might say
that there's security failings to be
interrogated but you know online abuse
is it is its own issue and i think you
know rather than maybe connecting it to
his death it
would be more any sort of change that
would be pushed by him he'd be more
about something that he was concerned
about well i suppose the connection is
that it just increases the fear of the
member of parliament uh if they have i
mean then margaret hodge told adam
bolton today she'd received 90 000
abusive social media mentions in a
two-month period the experience makes
her think very carefully about tweeting
anything at all that's around 1500 per
day she doesn't hold surgeries anymore
uh preferring to tackle it through a
different route i mean these this is
this is cowering people harry isn't it
this uh you know the way they have to
listen to this rubbish i mean slightly
two minds about this is just sort of
sort of touched on there i think it is
important that we don't conflate these
two issues and
there is a really really stark
conversation to be had about um whether
our security services are
able to cope with this new sort of lone
radicalized warfare it's very hard to
stop someone buying a knife
and doing something random there's
security elements analysts we
spoke to today and we're quoted in the
paper tomorrow has called them the sort
of nike terrorists they're really hard
to spot and trace because they just do
it and there's no not very much warning
there's not very much lead time there's
no chatter around it and it's extremely
hard to
to control then there's also an entirely
separate debate to be had
as jeff said about the online anonymity
the abuse that the mps the mps get the
the the bitter irony of all this is
just today anyone seeming to even back
the idea or even trying to have this
conversation about the idea of taking
some of that tension out of politics you
know maybe addressing these issues
is hit themselves by a torrent of foul
abuse of online trolls you just have to
go with any of
any of our colleagues or any of the mps
who sort of put their head above the
power bit on this front and you'll see
it there something really does need to
be done but i do think these
conversations need to get incredibly
separate and one shouldn't really i
don't think be drowning out the other in
terms of column inches and broadcast
time
and discussion in parliament i think
because we need to have both of these
conversations within their own right
yeah and many people would suggest if
the police investigated every threat
made to anybody who puts their head
above the parapet in any way you know
there would be no time for any other
form of policing uh but in terms of the
anonymity just quitting you and your
article jessica uh campaigners have
warned that ending online anonymity
could put both whistleblowers and
pro-democracy campaigners in
authoritarian regimes at risk so there's
a there's a balance in in in every move
is there not um but let's go to the uh
the south end echo or the eye rather um
mps vow to meet public face to face
i guess this depends you know this is an
individual thing now isn't it certainly
what what's the overall impression
you're getting jessica
yes and i think um you know there are
there are certainly some mps who i spoke
to today and there are a few you know
fewer that were willing to say this in
public i think margaret hodges said it
and also tobias hell would have kind of
said it as well but um you know that
they they feel like it is getting too
risky to make the public face to face
and
they're
most mps don't feel that they feel like
that it's a it's a kind of vital part of
the current of the british parliamentary
system it's vital for people to be able
to meet their mps it's democratic for
them to be able to go and ask things
that they're elected representative but
frankly it also keeps them in touch and
one of the
inside pieces i've written today is you
know got an mp saying they know which of
their colleagues don't really do their
constituency surgeries as much as they
should do because they're just out of
touch um and that goes for mps out of
all parties they're people who kind of
have pet obsessions and they don't
really keep in touch with the the
complex housing welfare needs
immigration needs people who need to
challenge corporations when they've cut
off someone's energy bills for no reason
that's the kind of thing that mps need
to keep them grounded in the real world
and meeting people to face to face every
week as mp's you know including cabinet
ministers often do
um uh you know that the suspect himself
comes he is his mp is um
i is his kia stammering and star went
ahead with his constituency surgery
on friday and the everybody you know
most the vast majority of the house of
commons
you know do them but that's not today
they're not scared often they have they
know that that is the place where are
the most vulnerable they have to
advertise where they're going to be um
and and you know we know that
unfortunately that's what sir david ames
said it had
advertised exactly where he was going to
be um on friday and so it is obviously
you know a place where they're
vulnerable and one mp told me that
members of the public because she'd
received so many threats and people in
her local area had offered to come and
be kind of de facto bodyguards for her
at surgeries because um you know she
didn't feel like the police were really
doing anything or responding to any
concerns that she had but you know can
you have the police stationed outside
these places does that fundamentally
change the kind of you know the kind of
atmosphere the environment is people can
come and raise their issues i don't know
it's it's a tricky balance to strike
but what we have learned if we look at
the uh the echo the south end castle
point rayleigh and rochford paper as it
says on there on the banner headline
there um is what constituency mps can
deliver for their people um
we heard from the prime minister today
that sir david's views often confounded
expectation and defied easy stereotype
that he was the master of private
members bills and ten-minute rule bills
and uh and we also heard during the the
tributes today that one of the main
reasons why he put his dog forward for
what was it parliamentary westminster
dog of the year i can't remember was
that the dog was a real supporter of
south end becoming a city that's one of
the reasons i mean there's some lovely
touches today and uh and as we see there
there there it is so uh south end um
confirmed by the queen harry
yeah look at the you know the crowning
touch of a 20-year campaign and as we
said earlier very sad one but again it
just kind of shows you as you said
exactly what an mp can achieve and if
they you know if they do spend their
lives about benches and private members
bills and campaigns and working across
the house which you have to do if you
can become these sort of powerful
backbenchers you need to support right
across the aisle um and i do think that
is you know
one of the most cherished parts of our
democratic system if you look across the
pond to america there used to be days
where senators would be carried aloft on
the shoulders of voters
and congressman and the like would go
door-to-door and that's all gone now you
know american politicians are surrounded
by multi layers of security someone was
telling me a lovely story today that um
angela merkel when she used to uh get
behind the scenes at um at some eu
summits would uh would say to david
cameron oh david david come here tell us
tell them about your surgeries you know
what have you had this week what have
you heard and he regales tales of you
know someone coming to complain that
school kids were throwing conkers at his
greenhouse or something so parochial or
minor like that but which is the bread
and butter of the british democratic
system i think it keeps our politicians
uh humble and it keeps them grounded in
a way that they do have to go from the
corridors of power to the armored limos
and
and the raf jets flying around the world
to friday afternoon in the constituency
meeting normal people with normal
concerns and and hearing problems and i
think if that link was broken it will be
you know forever to this country's
detriment and i think david amos not
wanted to put words in his mouth but i
think he would have he was a massive
supporter for this and i think if his
legacy was to see that weakened in any
way then i think that'll be a real
tragedy however there is on the other
side of the coin how do you do it if you
put policemen into these constituency
surgeries
lots of people you might suspect might
not come forward and be so open
uh and so it's that balance is it's
notoriously hard
uh problem to solve one which would have
been solved already but i can't help but
think the problem is it's going to end
up resulting however however however you
can't
downlink between the between the mp and
their people uh and that's yeah that is
it needs to be avoided yes sorry we we
we have to just take a break and come
back with more um but uh the echo south
essex remembers its champion full ten
pages remembering the person that stood
up for all those reasons as you said uh
for for those people who lived in that
area um lost muscle to come next why
just 90 000 homes might be able to
benefit from boiler vouchers to switch
from gas the news from the government
this evening back with that in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me the guardian's
chief political correspondent jessica
elgot and the political editor of the
sun harry cole and harry you and your
team have got the the pm writing in your
paper
about this idea to switch over boilers
and a government grant to help us do it
uh yes finally the long-awaited uh heat
and building strategy which is how the
earth uh government are gonna meet the
2050
carbon
net zero carbon promises
including as we've discussed many times
on this program ripping out boilers and
replacing them with expensive heat pumps
and it turns out actually tomorrow's
going to be a bit of a hopscotch it's
going to be a bit of a
you know wing it see where we are in 10
years hopefully the technology will move
on but in the meantime have five grand
to uh to to to replace your boiler with
a heat pump whether it'll work but
they'll be queuing up around the blocks
uh to do this uh i i'm not so sure yeah
i mean it's generally air source heat
pumps you need quite a lot of land or a
very deep borehole don't you for a
ground source heat pump pump which some
people you know find quite bulky quite
expensive uh the idea you get five grand
to make it the same cost as if you're
replacing to your gas boiler but not
enough people will be helped according
to the telegraph jessica
yeah i mean 90 000 um homes is i mean
it's nothing that's not i mean that's
you know obviously it's better than
nothing probably i should say but um but
it's not it's not going to be the thing
that helps us hit that that that target
i mean what the pm's essentially banking
on here is that this subsidy means that
by you know by the time that more
boilers need replacing that the the
price would have gone down and be these
effectively you know kind of betting the
house on that on that happening and if
that doesn't happen we're gonna have to
you know gonna have to see that that
subsidy increase or or a different plan
altogether but um but yeah that that on
its own is certainly not gonna be enough
to do the job uh it uh starts in april
for anyone who wants the 5000 uh
initially lasting for three years funded
with 450 million pounds uh which is
where they get the 90 000 from we'll
talk more about that soon thank you very
much indeed harry and jessica thank you